quand direct jean paul moreau président
de l'union des journalistes ivoiriens de
france
bonjour jean paul euros merci de
répondre à nos questions les premiers
résultats sont donc attendus dans les
prochaines 48 heures voit même voire
même cet après midi à quoi s'attendre
selon vous pour le sens l'enjeu était
pour le pouvoir d'abidjan de réussi à
organiser cette élection je pense que
pour l'instant que se satisfaire d'avoir
pu organiser une élection même si ça a
été dans des conditions difficiles
émaillées de violences qui ont envoyé
spécial là vient de lui signifier tout à
l'heure beaucoup de régions et beaucoup
de violence a beaucoup de régions
l'élection s'est déroulée à abidjan dans
et sa région de façon j'ai déjà bu l'eau
et est désertique dans certaines régions
n'y a vraiment pas eu de vote
là où il ya eu des votes c'est un peu
c'était c'était le désert le taux de
participation était très faible et dans
j'étais dans la région septentrionale
qui est la lutte est le fief du
président alassane ouattara
les élections se sont déroulées de façon
j'ai dit les tranquillement d'avoir
quand on regarde tout ça on peut tout
simplement dit qu'aujourd'hui
sept mois plus tôt à au regard du taux
de participation qui sera le vrai enjeu
de cette élection parce que c'est à
partir de cela que le l'opposition va
certainement durci son discours ou en
tout cas le nourrisson discours du taux
de participation a fonctionné cela dira
que le taux de participation c'est ça le
sait le taux réel de deux longs
pourcentage réel de ce que vaut le
président alassane ouattara dans des
opinions publiques nationales et c'est
tellement le reste c'est ce sera le leu
leu ce que le plan que l'opposition bas
dans sa majorité d'antan dans l'opinion
dans l'opinion
voilà un peu les enjeux de cette
élection a le taux de participation que
tout le monde attend que tout le monde
guette mais qui visiblement liste des
parts récréation ce sera un indicateur
parce qu il selon vous alassane ouattara
va l'emporter c'est sa hausse est clair
c'est évident le présent votre avoir
remporté cette élection faut s'attendre
alors dans la rue est ce qu'on peut
s'attendre à un embrasement du pays
comme eux
en 2010 par exemple c'est d'atteindre
cet accord tous les voyants sont au
rouge déjà les ingrédients d'une crise
préélectorale ont été plantés on a vu
n'assiste à plusieurs dizaines de morts
depuis l'annoncé de la candidature du
candidat ouattara le 6 août dernier
aujourd'hui le jour du scrutin hier le
jour du scrutin on a eu plus d'une
dizaine de morts et maillard de t&d plus
beaucoup de blessés et maniant des
violences de 2,2 et tous deux issus de
cette élection a et il y a encore loupé
l'opposition l'a dit d'ailleurs qu'elle
ne reconnaîtra pas les résultats issus
de cette élection qui ne le
connaîtraient pas le président alassane
ouattara comme prochain président de la
république de côte d'ivoire
c'est à croire que nous savons que tous
en afrique mais les violences qui
découle des élections sont toujours
issus de des résultats contestés donc il
est acquis que le prochain jeu a le plus
de côte d'ivoire va connaître des temps
difficiles
alors si elle connaît des temps
difficiles que peuvent faire les autres
pays les observateurs cette l'union
européenne et l'onu ont appelé à un
scrutin je cite pacifique
quel rôle peut avoir la communauté
internationale justement cette et rôle
de facilitation que
les éditeurs et les observateurs
internationaux la cedeao qui aux yeux de
l'opposition y voit les et discréditer
parce que l'opposition allait mais
estime que la cedeao est partie prenante
dans cette dans ce scrutin au loin dans
cette crise ont le pouvoir
la cedeao en appel à naples et ils l'ont
dit clairement à une autorité et un an
ces chefs d'état africains et a demandé
à sa une facilitation de l'union l'union
africaine
moi je pense que c'est à ce niveau que
les choses pourront se prononcer
décanter il faudra une facilitation
entre le pouvoir d'abidjan et
l'opposition ou à l'impôt qu'ils
puissent encore une fois ça soit à
discuter pour que la côte d'ivoire ne
s'embrasse pas encore une fois parce que
tous les ingrédients comme je le disais
tantôt tous les ingrédients sont plantés
ou que la côte d'ivoire des lumières et
des as
vous parlez tout allant du du taux de
participation qui sera le véritable
indicateur selon vous par rapport aux
résultats
on sait que moins de la moitié des
citoyens sont inscrits sur les listes
électorales et qui ont pu retirer leur
carte d'électeur
du coup à partir de quand à partir de
quoi on pourra dire que cette élection
est légitime au concernant l'état des
lecteurs de lecteurs je crois que le
coup l'endroit est lassée après
disposition ou permet tous voilà qui
n'ont pas plu c'est qu'il est à deux des
vecteurs dans l'écouté avec l'attak lens
1-4 était toujours valable parce que le
permettait la prolongation de ceux de ce
document là donc du coup les ivoiriens
qui avaient une carte nationale
d'identité était considéré comme déjà
comme il suffit d'être sur la liste
électorale et pouvez-vous tilt autres la
question du retrait de la delà de la
carte d'électeur
l'upa est un indicateur véritablement un
indicateur précis mais il est clair
quand on voit l'ambiance électorale
l'ambiance à abidjan à les rues
d'abidjan étaient désertes habillant
qu'on connaît un samedi les rues sont
pleines de commerce plein de commerçants
les grands embouteillages au niveau de
2,2 du plateau de treichville mais ces
grandes capes de ces grandes villes de
sa grande copine d'abidjan tout était
désert quand on imagine la capitale et
que l'on paie politique de la côte
d'ivoire qui était coupée en deux qui
n'a pas voté
dont on imagine des grandes villes comme
la loi où le vote a été a été très
faible a tout simplement le on peut se
dire je ne suis pas sûr que les
élections
le taux de participation puce interoute
est passé maître jean-paul euros vous
êtes le président de l'union des
journalistes ivoiriens de france du coup
en france quel est l'état d'esprit parmi
la diaspora ivoirienne qui a voté depuis
l'hexagone depuis l'hexagone ici
l'élection s'est passée très bien très
bien c'est que c'est pour moi la lecture
tout simplement que je fais c'est qu'il
ya eu du masque on l'a vu hier sur des
images d'un jeu n'étant pas de ma part
de la part des autorités françaises ça a
été un grand manque de gd les deux
responsabilités
ce aubervilliers les toques l'époque des
faits le titre mon sens c'est un grand
poster à cette polo dupont d'habitude de
la cofidis de perm est prêt à près de
quarante mille ivoiriens seront trouvés
dans une zone maison sur les autres cas
ce problème de son problème technique
jean paul euros merci en tous les cas
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes le président
de l'union des journalistes ivoiriens de
france